it's crazy because normally i get to
talk to people about see like the card
season two but uh i don't know who has
survived i'm going to say most of you
but you're filming picard season 3 right
now so it's one of these things where um
i get to sort of say what can you tease
about picard season two and season three
season two has queue yeah and
season three
will have and see the return of jean-luc
picard
that is all i can say yeah
that is a great that's a great answer
were you guys told like nothing on three
yep
yeah
and and almost near
close to nothing for season two
yeah
it's one of these things that when i'm
talking to actors on a show like this
that you know where the secrets are very
secure it's hard because you want to
talk but anyway so i'll ask this for all
three of you i love learning about the
behind the scenes of the making of a
show things that fans wouldn't know
things that you know you guys are uh you
know privy to so what do you think
people would be surprised to learn about
the actual making of picard
uh well i mean i think one of the things
we were talking about is that how um i
think with these kinds of shows people
always think that you're not really on
that everything there's a lot of green
screen you're not on the set so you're
not really in the real places a lot of
it for us it all feels very very real
and the great thing about season two is
that we're in los angeles in the present
so we got to be you know we were and on
the set in the real set so it got it
feels very grounded in that respect
you're always in the in the reality and
of of where you are we have these
incredible um ships built and sets built
so everything feels very
very real even move you know even like
battle sequences feel more real than
what you would think so there's a lot of
uh
there's there's a lot of pretending but
it's all it's all grounded in a lot of a
lot of reality surrounding it which is
great
just getting to see
all of the legacy actors
together is um
one of the most special things about
doing this show and doing star trek in
general and seeing how
close they all actually are
and you you never quite know like with
all of my favorite shows that i watch
before i was like oh i hope that the
cast was like actually friends because
that would make me really happy and that
is how it is thankfully for our cast but
also for the cast of the next generation
when they all get together they are just
like
it's like it's the old times again like
they they they're back to being just
like their silly
goofy selves
i'd say just the time it takes to
even film one or two episodes people
don't realize uh
how much like even a minute of film like
takes i mean you put on an episode it
goes for 55 minutes and you're like well
that was quick but it it really is time
consuming it takes dedication sometimes
scenes
take days to film and it really is like
a credit to you know the cast and the
crew and everyone behind it it and it
really does help when you all get along
with each other and you've all got this
kind of
one-track mind and like vision and goal
that you want to kind of achieve and it
i feel like it reflects that we all care
oh for sure my last thing for you guys
because i'm going to be out of time i
love patrick stewart like i just love
him i've heard he's just awesome to be
around
how much do you have to pull back
wanting to just like geek out with him
about some of his previous roles and
just his career because it's so awesome
you don't have to pull back you just ask
him he'll tell you he'll tell you yeah
it's which is great you get to hear such
great stories and anecdotes about you
know who he's worked with and what he's
done in his time and all the theater
he's done is it's great because it
really feels like
like that that uh that we're part of a
group and an ensemble we're all sharing
stories but he's of course gonna have so
much more uh you know they're just so
much more epic yeah
i don't know if we're allowed to tell
you a lot of the stuff but i mean it's
just if you ask him about an episode
that he filmed or
uh
someone who had a cameo i mean like it's
just great hearing all these old stories
that
that he has and it kind of like
makes you feel like you're a part of
something like bigger yeah he's so
forthcoming with just
telling you about his life and telling
you about
his personal life even like he's he's
very open about that stuff so it kind of
makes everyone immediately feel like oh
we're world pals like we we we
we're on that level like he makes
everyone feel really at home
i got a wrap there i'm just gonna say i
really can't wait to see the rest of the
episodes and good luck uh uh filming the
finale um if perhaps you're filming it
right now hypothetically thank you thank
you
you